aujourd'hui c'est la fête au pays des
zones de ruck
une terre dont le kenya les a expulsés
il ya plus de 30 ans pour en faire un
parc pour touristes les andorrans y
veulent être reconnus comme les
propriétaires de leur territoire et
c'est ce qu'ils viennent d'obtenir au
terme d'un long procès contre le kenya
une première dans toute l'histoire du
pays
le jeune homme au milieu en rose c'est
nelson pour cet éleveur de 22 ans c'est
le plus beau jour de sa vie
c'est une journée très importante pour
nous une journée historique surtout pour
notre génération
le kenya
toutes les minorités du pays qui sont
opprimés par le même gouvernement
maintenant qu'il est possible de gagner
ils vont suivre notre stratégie aussi
devant les tribunaux
le lendemain matin nous retrouvons
nelson chez lui le jeune homme est
éleveur évier avec sa grand mère
[Musique]
lui s'occupe des vaches et elle des
chèvres
quand il parle des autorités kényanes il
n'a pas de mots assez durs pour
qualifier ce qu'elles ont fait subir à
son peuple
matin c'était tellement injuste que
quelqu'un vienne vous chercher et vous
ordonne de quitter votre terre pour vous
expulser sans jamais vous donner un
autre endroit où vivre c'est injuste
c'est comme si vous n'étiez pas un être
humain
sa maison c'est cet amas de tôle en tout
moins de 10 mètres carrés la chaleur y
est insoutenable une bonne partie de
l'année
leur alimentation de base du manioc et
du maïs
mais le vrai problème est ailleurs
pour trouver des pâturages
kilomètres pour trouver de l'eau et ce
qu'elles omettent a encore huit
kilomètres plus loin les causes
parce que la rivière dont nous dépendons
ici c'est une rivière saisonnière qui
est totalement asséché de décembre à mai
était et vous pouvez voir qu'ici il n'ya
pas une seule réserve d'eau prévus
son père il ne l'a jamais connue et sa
mère l'a abandonnée quand il était bébé
parce qu'elle était trop pauvre pour le
nourrir sans sa grand-mère nesle somme
serait mort
[Musique]
vous voyez la manière dont ils nous font
vivre sans argent dans un total
dénuement
j'espère que c'en est fini parce qu'on a
atteint notre but risque nous allons
récupérer notre terre
tout va changer maintenant qu'ils ont
gagné le droit de revivre sur les rives
du lac les andes d'oreilles n'auront
plus à marcher des heures pour chercher
de l'eau leur troupeau de vaches ne
risqueront plus de mourir à cause de la
sécheresse et apprendront à cohabiter
avec les flamands roses
il y aura du travail pour tout le monde
et peut-être même que la mère de nelson
reviendra en attendant il va découvrir
la terre de ses ancêtres
car aujourd'hui les portes du parc lui
sont ouvertes
c'est en compagnie d'un ancien que
nelson franchi l'entrée de la réserve
une plaque dorée fraîchement posée
rappelle que ces terres appartiennent
désormais aux zones de ruck
[Musique]
petit à petit ils vont réapprendre à
vivre près de leur lac
halak que l'unesco avait classé comme
patrimoine mondial de l'humanité sans
même se soucier qu'il appartenait avant
tout un peuple oublié de tous
[Musique]